Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. On Sunday, January 10, 1993, 54-year-old pig farmer Ralph Lulma and his 49-year-old wife Joan returned home from a week-long interstate trip. The couple, who lived in the Victorian country town of Antwerp, had driven four and a half hours west to attend a six-day religious convention in the South Australian capital of Adelaide.
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛心的事件。如果您在任何时候觉得需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关保密支持的建议电话号码，请参阅您的应用程序上或我们网站上的本期节目说明。1993年1月10日星期日，54岁的养猪农场主拉尔夫·乌尔马和49岁的妻子琼结束了为期一周的州际旅行回到家中。这对夫妇住在维多利亚州的乡村小镇安特卫普，他们向西驱车四个半小时，前往南澳大利亚州首府阿德莱德参加为期六天的宗教大会。
Ralph, a devout and ardent Christian, had been eager to attend the event, and while Joan didn't share her husband's fervour, she attended church regularly and so agreed to accompany him. The vacation had passed without incident, but shortly after their arrival home, Joan started to behave oddly. She had difficulty concentrating on tasks, would frequently change outfits throughout the day, was restless, and struggled to fall asleep. According to Ralph, as time went on she also started making peculiar noises and adopting
拉尔夫是一位虔诚的基督徒，他一直热切期盼参加这次活动，而琼虽然没有她丈夫那么狂热，但也经常去教堂，于是同意陪他前往。假期过得很平静，但在他们回家后不久，琼开始出现异常行为。她难以集中精力做事，一天中会频繁更换衣服，坐立不安，并且难以入睡。据拉尔夫回忆，随着时间的推移，她还开始发出奇怪的声音并表现出
different personas. On one occasion, she acted as though she were a sheep shearer, speaking in a tone and manner consistent with a farm hand. On another, she claimed to be a sex worker, while describing the activities she had participated in with supposed clients. It wasn't the first time Ralph had witnessed a Joan behaving this way. Two years earlier, she was hospitalized briefly for mental illness, but had made a fairly quick recovery and had been in good health ever since. Now, it appeared her symptoms were returning.
不同的个性。有一次，她表现得像个剪羊毛工，说话的语气和方式与农场工人如出一辙。还有一次，她自称是一名性工作者，同时描述了她与所谓客户一起参与的活动。这并不是拉尔夫第一次看到琼有这样的行为。两年前，她曾因精神疾病短暂住院，但很快就康复了，此后身体一直很好。现在，她的症状似乎又复发了。
Over the course of the next two weeks, they seemed to worsen, particularly at night time. On the evening of Friday, January 22, Ralph returned home to find Joan waving her arms and dancing in their properties' paddocks. Deeply troubled by the way his wife's well-being had deteriorated, Ralph prayed to God for guidance. The Wimmerer The Wimmerer is a regional inland district in Victoria's West, predominantly characterized by dry, flat farmlands
在接下来的两周里，这些症状似乎恶化了，尤其是在夜间。1月22日星期星期五晚上，拉尔夫回到家，发现琼在他们房产的牧场里挥舞着手臂跳舞。由于妻子健康状况的恶化深感不安，拉尔夫向上帝祈求指引。维梅尔（The Wimmera）是维多利亚州西部的一个内陆地区，主要特征是干燥平坦的农田，
and a 278-kilometer intermittent river that bears the same name. Passing through the region's unofficial capital city of Horsham, the river winds west and then continues north to Antwerp, a tiny outback town named after the Belgian home city of an early European settler. In the 1860s, two Protestant missionaries arrived in Antwerp and built a church and mission where they aimed to convert the local indigenous population. The mission was closed 40 years later due to low congregation numbers, and today stands as a tourist attraction.
以及一条长达278公里、时断时续、同名河流。这条河穿过该地区非官方的首府霍舍姆，向西蜿蜒，然后继续向北流向安特卫普，这是一个位于内陆的小镇，以一位早期欧洲定居者的比利时故乡命名。19世纪60年代，两位新教传教士来到安特卫普，建造了一座教堂和传教站，旨在将当地土著居民皈依基督教。由于会众人数稀少，该传教站于40年后关闭，如今已成为一个旅游景点。
Towards the end of the 20th century, Antwerp was home to just 63 inhabitants. It had a licensed general store, a rail siding, and a small station where residents could catch a bus to Horsham twice a week. The two-lane Dimboola Rainbow Road carved through the town's sprawling fields, which were dotted by scrubs and eucalyptus trees, and several disused grain silos stood out against the mostly natural landscape. Ralf and Joan Vollmer had moved to Antwerp in the late 1980s, purchasing one of the town's traditional farmsteads where they raised pigs. Born in Germany in 1938, right before the outbreak
在20世纪末，安特卫普仅有63名居民。这里有一家持牌综合商店、一个铁路侧线和一个小车站，居民可以在那里每周两次乘车前往霍舍姆。双车道的丁布拉-雷恩博路穿过镇上广袤的田野，田野点缀着灌木丛和桉树，几座废弃的粮仓在主要由自然风貌构成的风景中格外显眼。拉尔夫和琼·沃尔默于20世纪80年代末搬到安特卫普，买下了镇上一处传统的农场并养猪。拉尔夫于1938年出生于德国，正值
of World War II, Ralf had emigrated to Australia with his family when he was a teenager. He had completed primary school in Germany, but the move interrupted his education, and he never enrolled in secondary school. His family moved to the Melbourne suburb of Caulfield, and his parents both worked in factory production. Eventually, they saved enough money from working overtime to afford a small rural property in Gippsland, a region in the states southeast. Ralf grew up to be a softly spoken man who found it difficult to trust others and mostly kept to himself, but when he did form friendships, they were extremely strong. He worked as a farmhand and performed odd jobs before meeting his first wife and settling down
第二次世界大战爆发前夕，他十几岁时随家人移民到澳大利亚。他在德国读完了小学，但搬家打断了他的学业，他再也没有上过中学。他的家人搬到了墨尔本的考菲尔德郊区，父母都在工厂打工。最终，他们通过加班攒下的钱，买下了吉普斯兰（该州东南部的一个地区）的一处小型乡村房产。拉尔夫长大后成为一个说话轻声细语的人，觉得很难信任别人，大部分时间独来独往，但一旦建立起友谊，就会非常深厚。他曾做过农场工人和零工，后来遇到了第一任妻子并在
in the Gippsland town of Yarum. The couple had two sons, but the marriage ended in the mid-1970s. Following the divorce, Ralf remained single until 1986 when he met and fell in love with Joan. Joan Lenora Taylor was a petite woman with short, wavy, light brown hair, who was typically described as shy, gentle, and loving. Her childhood and early adulthood were marred by sexual abuse, and she was later diagnosed with schizophrenia, resulting in several stints in mental health hospitals, which left her with a fear of psychiatric care. She struggled to make friends and maintain ongoing work, though she adored children and had been employed as a nanny for a time. As a young woman, she married and had a baby, but was left in a state of anxiety and blame
吉普斯兰镇亚勒姆安顿下来。两人育有两个儿子，但这段婚姻在20世纪70年代中期结束了。离婚后，拉尔夫一直单身，直到1986年遇到了琼并坠入爱河。琼·莱诺拉·泰勒是一个身材娇小、留着短卷浅棕色头发的女性，通常被形容为害羞、温柔和充满爱心。她的童年和成年早期饱受性虐待的折磨，后来被诊断出患有精神分裂症，曾多次进出精神病院，这让她对精神科治疗产生了恐惧。她很难交到朋友并维持长期的工作，尽管她非常喜欢孩子，曾做过一段时间的保姆。年轻时，她结过婚并生下了一个孩子，但在
when her husband took his own life. Her life appeared to turn around in her early 40s when she met Ralf, who later compared their early relationship to a miracle. The new couple decided to start a fresh life together in an entirely different part of the state, settling on the Wimmera region and purchasing the farm in Antwerp in 1988. Their new home was a single story weatherboard farmhouse with a wide veranda that sat at the end of a 500-metre dirt driveway framed by several trees. The rear of the property backed onto the banks of the Wimmera River. Joan, an avid gardener, immediately set about planting a neat border of garden beds around the house and establishing a greenhouse. She also decorated her new home with vases,
丈夫自杀后，她陷入了焦虑和自责的状态。40出头时，她遇到了拉尔夫，生活似乎有了转机，拉尔夫后来将他们早期的感情比作奇迹。这对新夫妇决定在州内一个完全不同的地方开始崭新的生活，他们选中了维梅尔地区，并于1988年买下了安特卫普的农场。他们的新家是一栋单层木板农舍，带有宽阔的游廊，坐落在一条长500米的泥土车道尽头，四周环绕着几棵树。房产背面紧靠维梅尔河岸。琼是一位狂热的园艺爱好者，她立刻着手在房屋周围种下一排整齐的花坛，并建了一个温室。她还用花瓶、
porcelain ornaments, and cat figurines. The couple didn't involve themselves in the local community, but those who met Joan in town described her as friendly. Neither Ralf nor Joan had been religious when they met, but several years into their relationship they discovered their faith and became Christians. They married at Horsham's Salvation Army Church in 1989 and began attending Sunday Mass there. Ralf was a far more impassioned believer compared to his wife, spending his spare time listening to hymns and reading religious texts, while Joan preferred to watch television. She was content to be involved with the church, but in the words of one local minister, not to be fanatical about it. In contrast, Ralf was eager to learn as much as he
瓷器装饰品和猫咪小雕像装饰新家。这对夫妇不怎么参与当地社区活动，但在镇上遇到琼的人都形容她很友好。拉尔夫和琼相遇时都没有宗教信仰，但在交往几年后，他们发现了信仰并成为了基督徒。1989年，他们在霍舍姆的救世军教堂结婚，并开始在那里参加周日弥撒。与妻子相比，拉尔夫是一个更加充满激情的信徒，他把业余时间花在听圣歌和阅读宗教文本上，而琼则更喜欢看电视。她满足于参与教堂活动，但用当地一位牧师的话说，她并没有狂热到那种地步。相比之下，拉尔夫渴望尽可能多地了解
could about Christianity. For most of his life he had only attended church for weddings and funerals, but after converting he would constantly engage others on the topic, listening enthusiastically to those who claimed the deep knowledge of the Bible. In their home's kitchen he hung a plaque that read, Christ is the head of this house, the unseen guest at every meal, the silent listener to every conversation. Within two years of moving to Antwerp, Joan began exhibiting signs of a mental health crisis. In the spring of 1990, she suddenly became extremely restless, was unable to sleep, and struggled to concentrate on tasks or conversations, yet seemed oblivious that something was wrong. She also became fixated on her childhood, discussing it frequently in a childlike voice.
关于基督教的知识。在他大半生里，他只在婚礼和葬礼上去过教堂，但皈依后，他不断与他人谈论这个话题，热情地倾听那些自称对圣经有深刻了解的人。他在家里的厨房挂了一块牌匾，上面写着：“基督是这户的主人，每一次用餐时看不见的客人，每一次谈话时沉默的倾听者。”搬到安特卫普两年内，琼开始表现出精神健康危机的迹象。1990年春天，她突然变得极其焦躁不安，无法入睡，难以集中精力做事或交谈，却似乎对出了问题毫无所知。她还对自己的童年产生执念，经常用孩子气的声音谈论它。
One day, she told Ralf that she had done a painting for him, only to reveal she had coded his car in house paint. From the beginning, Ralf suspected that dark forces were responsible for his wife's changes in behaviour. He noticed an expression in her eyes that terrified him, describing them as being bright red, almost glowing, almost like coals. When she was overcome with a fit of rage outside, a frightened Ralf locked himself in the house. He consulted Salvation Army captains at the church the couple attended, seeking guidance on the matter. Rejecting his suggestion there was, quote, an evil presence in Joan, the captains instead offered the couple marriage counselling. Displeased with this response, Ralf scheduled a doctor's appointment
有一天，她告诉拉尔夫她为他画了一幅画，结果却发现她用房屋油漆涂抹了拉尔夫的汽车。从一开始，拉尔夫就怀疑黑暗力量是导致妻子行为改变的原因。他注意到她眼中有一种让他感到恐惧的神情，形容那眼神红得发亮，几乎像在发光，犹如煤炭一般。当她在外面情绪失控爆发时，吓坏了的拉尔夫把自己锁在屋里。他咨询了两人所去的救世军教堂的队长，就此事寻求指导。队长们拒绝了他关于“琼身上存在邪灵”的说法，转而建议这对夫妇接受婚姻咨询。拉尔夫对这个回答很不满意，便预约了
for Joan at a medical clinic in the nearby town of Dimboola. The general practitioner concluded that Joan was suffering from mental illness and should be admitted as an involuntary patient to a psychiatric hospital. In late September, she was taken to Lakeside Mental Health Hospital in the regional city of Ballarat, a three-hour drive southeast from her home. Psychiatrists there diagnosed Joan with anxiety, depression, schizophrenia and hypomania, a mood disorder which can cause increased energy, difficulty concentrating, restlessness and irritability. She remained at the hospital for three weeks and by mid-October, her sleep pattern had improved, though it still wasn't back to normal. Upon release, doctors prescribed to
附近丁布拉镇一家医疗诊所的医生，为琼看病。全科医生断定琼患有精神疾病，应作为非自愿病人收入精神病院。9月下旬，她被送到位于巴拉瑞特区域城市的湖滨精神健康医院，该地距离她家东南方向有三小时的车程。那里的精神科医生诊断琼患有焦虑症、抑郁症、精神分裂症和轻躁狂（一种可能导致精力增加、注意力难以集中、坐立不安和易怒的情绪障碍）。她在医院住了三个星期，到10月中旬，她的睡眠模式有所改善，尽管仍未恢复正常。出院后，医生给
Joan an antipsychotic medication called dioridazine, which was then commonly used to treat schizophrenia. They instructed her to take it for 12 months, cautioning her that if she stopped, there was a strong possibility of relapse within the next two years. Nine days after Joan's release, she was still struggling with persistent restlessness, so she and Ralf made another doctor's appointment. Although Joan was coherent, the doctor noted she had difficulty remaining seated and expressed that the problem might have been the thiorridazine, as agitation was a side effect of the drug. Joan's dosage was halved and she was also
琼开了一种名为硫利达嗪（dioridazine）的抗精神病药物，当时这种药常用于治疗精神分裂症。他们指示她服用12个月，并警告她如果停药，在未来两年内极有可能会复发。在琼出院九天后，她仍然饱受持续坐立不安的困扰，于是她和拉尔夫又预约了一次医生。尽管琼神志清醒，但医生注意到她很难坐稳，并表示问题可能是硫利达嗪引起的，因为烦躁是该药物的副作用。琼的剂量被减半，医生还
prescribed a second medication to help manage the restlessness. The doctor asked the couple to return in five days for a follow-up appointment, but she never saw them again. Joan's continued suffering convinced Ralf that the doctors were unable to help. He suggested to Joan that she submit to deliverance, a form of ministry similar to an exorcism, in which an individual is cleansed of evil spirits and demons. Joan refused, telling her husband, there's nothing wrong with me. Ralf then turned to his religious friends for advice and was instructed to pray to God to bind the spirits. He did so, and when Joan's health improved shortly after, Ralf attributed her recovery to his prayers, and she ceased taking
给她开了一种辅助药物来帮助控制焦躁不安。医生要求这对夫妇五天后来复诊，但她再也没有见到他们。琼持续的痛苦让拉尔夫确信医生们束手无策。他建议琼接受“释放”（deliverance，一种类似于驱魔的宗教仪式，旨在将个人身上的邪灵和恶魔清除）。琼拒绝了，告诉丈夫：“我没有毛病。”拉尔夫于是向他的宗教朋友寻求建议，被告知要向上帝祈祷以驱逐这些灵魂。他照做了，当琼的健康状况不久后有所改善时，拉尔夫将她的康复归功于自己的祈祷，于是她停止了
her medication. Seeing Joan's recovery increased Ralf's faith in God even further, and religion became the focal point of his life. One neighbour would later recall that while he could have a normal conversation with the Joan, it was impossible to talk to Ralf without the subject of religion being raised. In his quest to find a like-minded people, Ralf had become acquainted with a couple named John and Leanne Reichenbach, both aged 30, who had encouraged him to pray for Joan's recovery. The Reichenbachs resided on a remote farmstead in the town of Glenleigh, located roughly 28km west of Antwerp. They had met through their involvement in the Lutheran faith, with Leanne attending services in a town south of Portiam, and John's family
服药。看到琼的康复进一步增强了拉尔夫对上帝的信仰，宗教成了他生活的中心。一位邻居后来回忆说，虽然他可以和琼进行正常的交谈，但如果不提起宗教话题，根本无法和拉尔夫对话。为了寻找志同道合的人，拉尔夫结识了一对名叫约翰和莉安·赖兴巴赫（John and Leanne Reichenbach）的夫妇，两人都是30岁，曾鼓励他为琼的康复祈祷。赖兴巴赫夫妇住在格伦利镇的一个偏远农场，位于安特卫普以西约28公里处。他们因为信仰路德宗而相识，莉安在波蒂姆南边的一个小镇参加礼拜，而约翰的家族
being well-regarded elders of another nearby church. They married, and by the early 1990s had four children. Over time, they found themselves increasingly drawn to charismatic Christianity, a fundamentalist movement that emphasises abilities believed to be bestowed by the Holy Spirit, such as speaking in tongues, performing miracles, and being able to heal the sick. During the early 1990s, the charismatic movement was on the rise throughout the Wimmera region, becoming increasingly popular with individuals who had previously practiced more conventional branches of Christianity. John and Leanne Reichenbach believed they had a divine calling to exercise demons and began performing deliverances. They also established their own prayer circle at
是附近另一间教堂备受尊崇的长老。两人结婚后，到20世纪90年代初育有四个孩子。随着时间推移，他们发现自己越来越被灵恩派基督教所吸引，这是一个强调圣灵所赐能力的基要主义运动，例如说方言、行神迹以及医治病人。20世纪90年代初，灵恩运动在整个维梅尔地区兴起，对那些以前实践更传统基督教分支的人越来越有吸引力。约翰和莉安·赖兴巴赫坚信他们有驱除恶魔的神圣呼召，并开始实施释放仪式。他们还在
their home, with groups ranging from 6 to 25 people gathering there to sing hymns and study biblical passages. Soon, Ralph Volma was a regular attendee and developed a close friendship with the couple, considering them to be the only two truly spirit-filled people of their entire congregation. However, the Reichenbach's involvement with the charismatic movement led to clashes with their Lutheran minister. When he pointed out that some of their new beliefs contradicted the Bible's teachings, they would argue that the Lord had spoken to them personally. Their disagreements with the church's doctrine eventually led to them being excommunicated excommunicated from their congregation in late 1992.
家中建立了自已的祈祷小组，有6到25人不等的群体聚集在那里唱圣经赞美诗和研读经文。不久，拉尔夫·沃尔玛（Ralph Volma）成为了常客，并与这对夫妇结下了深厚的友谊，认为他们是整个会众中仅有的两个真正充满圣灵的人。然而，赖兴巴赫夫妇参与灵恩运动导致了他们与路德宗牧师的冲突。当牧师指出他们的一些新信仰与圣经教导相矛盾时，他们却辩称主曾亲自对他们说过话。他们与教堂教义的分歧最终导致他们在1992年底被逐出会众（excommunicated）。
In early January 1993, Ralph and Joan travelled to Adelaide to attend a six-day charismatic movement convention that the Reichenbachs had recommended to them. The week-long event was characterized by lots of singing, preaching, and people performing minor miracles such as healing and casting out demons. Throughout it all, Joan seemed moody and withdrawn, but the trip passed without any significant incidents. When the couple arrived back home on Sunday, January 10, Joan's manic symptoms returned and quickly worsened. She was once again restless and unable to sleep, and according to Ralph, would snort like a pig, make aggressive facial expressions that he compared to an angry dog,
1993年1月上旬，拉尔夫和琼前往阿德莱德参加赖兴巴赫夫妇推荐的为期六天的灵恩运动大会。这行为期一周的活动以大量的歌唱、布道以及人们表演行医治和驱魔等微小神迹为特点。在这期间，琼显得情绪低落、离群索居，但整个行程没有发生任何重大事故。1月10日星期日，当这对夫妇回到家中时，琼的狂躁症状复发并迅速恶化。她再次坐立不安、无法入睡，据拉尔夫说，她会像猪一样哼哼，做出他比作生气恶犬的富有攻击性的面部表情，
swear loudly, and speak about lewd activities. Ralph attributed Joan's behaviour to spiritual problems. When he had prayed to bind the evil spirit within her two years earlier, he believed he had rendered it ineffective but failed to cast it out. Now, he suspected it had been reawakened by the strong spiritual atmosphere and nourishment of the convention and was rebelling against it. Over the next 10 days, Ralph prayed often for guidance, but worried that he was harassing God with concerns that he was already aware of. As a reminder to himself, Ralph painted the words Stop Telling Father Your Needs in red paint on an outside wall of the property's pigsty. On Thursday, January 21, 63-year-old Roma Karris caught the bus from Horsham to Antwerp to stay
大声咒骂，并谈论淫秽的活动。拉尔夫将琼的行为归咎于灵性问题。两年前，当他祈祷束缚她体内的邪灵时，他认为自己已经削弱了它的效力，但未能将其驱逐。现在，他怀疑它被大会强大的属灵氛围和滋养重新唤醒，并正在对此进行反抗。在接下来的10天里，拉尔夫经常祈求指引，但又担心自己用上帝已经知道的事情去打扰祂。为了提醒自己，拉尔夫在房产猪圈的外墙上用红漆写下了“别告诉父亲你的需求”（Stop Telling Father Your Needs）这几个字。1月21日星期四，63岁的罗马·卡里斯（Roma Karris）乘巴士从霍舍姆来到安特卫普，与她的朋友
with her friend to Joan Volma. It was the middle of summer and temperatures in the region were consistently soaring above 40 degrees Celsius. When Roma greeted Joan, she was shocked to find her friend to dress in a nighty and heavy dressing gown but with ice-cold hands. Throughout the visit, Joan restacked crockery, pulled apart flowers from a bouquet Roma had given her and sang in a peculiar voice that Roma described as lovely like a nightingale. Roma also observed that Joan's stomach appeared to be swollen. Joan told Roma that she was both expecting a baby and that the swelling was due to a cancerous tumor. She insisted that there were people on the property who wanted to rape her,
琼·沃尔玛呆在一起。当时正值盛夏，该地区的温度持续飙升至40摄氏度以上。当罗马向琼打招呼时，她惊讶地发现朋友穿着睡衣和厚重的晨袍，但双手冰凉。在探访期间，琼重新整理餐具、撕碎罗马送给她的花束，并用一种罗马形容为像夜莺一样悦耳的奇怪声音唱歌。罗马还观察到琼的肚子似乎肿胀了。琼告诉罗马，她既怀了孕，而且腹部肿胀也是由于癌症肿瘤造成的。她坚称房产里有人想要强奸她，
but when she tried to point them out to her friend, Roma saw nothing. Believing that Joan was heading for, quote, a nervous breakdown, Roma told Ralph of her concerns on the following morning of Friday, January 22, before returning home. That evening, Ralph returned home from shopping to find Joan dancing barefoot in the paddocks while waving her arms and calling out to him. He escorted her into the house only for Joan to run away and be found later that night four kilometers away. Deeply disturbed, Ralph prayed to God for guidance as to where he should turn for help. Believing he received an answer to reach
但当她试图向朋友指出这些人时，罗马什么也没看到。罗马认为琼正走向“精神崩溃”，于是在第二天（1月22日星期五）回家前向拉尔夫表达了她的担忧。那天晚上，拉尔夫购物回家，发现琼赤脚在牧场里跳舞，一边挥舞着手臂一边大声呼唤他。他把她护送进屋，结果琼却跑开，并在那天深夜在四公里外被找到。深感不安的拉尔夫向上帝祈求指引，该去哪里寻求帮助。他相信自己得到了回应，要
out to the Reichenbachs, he phoned John and asked him to come over. John arrived at the Roma residence at around 11.30 p.m. He and Leanne had participated in as many as 20 deliverances by this time, and upon seeing the state that Joan was in, John quickly deduced that she was a victim of demonic possession. He told Ralph that the deliverance was no longer an option but a necessary action in order to save her soul. Ralph agreed, and the two of them stayed awake all night praying for Joan and reading passages aloud from the Bible. The next morning of Saturday, January 23, Leanne Reichenbach arrived and took her husband's place by Joan's side while John returned home to
联系赖兴巴赫夫妇，于是给约翰打电话请他过来。约翰于晚上11点30分左右抵达罗马的住所。此时他和莉安已经参与了多达20次释放仪式，看到琼的状态后，约翰迅速推断出她是恶魔附身的受害者。他告诉拉尔夫，释放仪式已不再是一个选项，而是拯救她灵魂的必要行动。拉尔夫表示同意，两人整夜未眠，为琼祈祷并大声朗读圣经段落。第二天早上（1月23日星期六），莉安·赖兴巴赫赶到并接替丈夫守在琼身边，而约翰则回家照看
the couple's children. She phoned other members of their circle to ask for their guidance and assistance in praying for Joan. At the top of her list was Lea Klugsten, a 77-year-old Baptist who resided in the town of Rainbow, 52 kilometers north of Antwerp. The Reichenbachs considered Lea to be something of a spiritual leader, as she claimed to speak directly with God. After consulting with Leanne over the telephone, Lea came to the conclusion that Joan was possessed by not one but 10 demonic entities and provided advice on how to expel the evil spirits. Following Lea's instructions, Ralph and Leanne had Joan sit in a chair at one end of the kitchen while they sat at the other, reciting biblical passages, praying, and asking Joan questions
两人的孩子。她打电话给他们祈祷圈的其他成员，寻求他们对为琼祈祷的指导和协助。她名单上的第一位是莉亚·克卢格斯滕（Lea Klugsten），一位77岁的浸信会信徒，住在安特卫普以北52公里处的雷恩博（Rainbow）镇。赖兴巴赫夫妇认为莉亚算得上是一位属灵领袖，因为她声称能直接与上帝对话。在电话咨询莉安后，莉亚得出结论：琼不是被一个，而是被10个恶魔附身，并就如何驱逐邪灵提供了建议。按照莉亚的指示，拉尔夫和莉安让琼坐在厨房一端的椅子上，他们坐在另一端，
while Christian music played in the background. This pattern repeated over the next two days. Ralph and Leanne's deliverance sessions commenced during the mid-afternoon and continued throughout the night, sometimes not concluding until 5am. Occasionally, John Reichenbach would join them in person, but other times they regularly called him for advice, along with Lea and several other prayer circle members. After three days with no change in Joan's behavior, it was decided that they needed someone else to join them and strengthen their efforts. David Klingner was a 28-year-old contract harvester who had grown up in northern New South Wales but now lived in South Australia. He had attended the Reichenbach's prayer circles
在背景播放的基督教音乐中背诵圣经段落、祈祷并向琼提问。这种模式在接下来的两天里重复着。拉尔夫和莉安的释放会议在下午中期开始，并持续到整夜，有时直到凌晨5点才结束。有时，约翰·赖兴巴赫会亲自加入他们，但其他时候他们会定期打电话向他以及莉亚和祈祷圈的其他几位成员征求意见。在琼的行为连续三天没有改变后，大家决定需要找其他人加入并加强他们的努力。大卫·克林格（David Klingner）是一名28岁的合同收割机操作员，在澳大利亚新南威尔士州北部长大，但现在住在南澳大利亚州。他曾
on a number of occasions, where he had become acquainted with Ralph Fulmer as well. David had also met Joan and already harboured some suspicions about her, even before receiving phone calls from Leanne Reichenbach explaining that Joan was undergoing a deliverance. He had seen the vomers at a New Year's Eve prayer gathering four weeks earlier and thought that Joan had a blank expression on her face during the service. At one stage, he believed he saw her eyes roll back into her head. From that moment, he suspected there was a demonic presence in her and now that had seemingly been confirmed. When the group asked him to join them, he felt it was his duty to assist. On Tuesday, January 26, David made the considerable journey across the state
多次参加赖兴巴赫的祈祷圈，在那里他也结识了拉尔夫·富尔默（Ralph Fulmer）。大卫也见过琼，甚至在接到莉安·赖兴巴赫打来的解释琼正在经历释放仪式的电话之前，他就已经对琼产生了一些怀疑。四周前，他在一次新年前夜的祈祷聚会上见过这对夫妇，并认为琼在礼拜期间脸上带着空白的表情。一度，他以为看到她的眼睛翻进脑后。从那一刻起，他怀疑她体内有恶魔的存在，而现在这似乎得到了证实。当这个群体邀请他加入时，他觉得协助是自己的责任。1月26日星期二，大卫长途跋涉跨过州界
border to Antwerp. Upon arriving at the property, he felt that the atmosphere there was like that of a quote, spiritual battle between God and Satan. He prayed and read from the Bible along with Ralph and Leanne. The trio maintained their efforts throughout the entire day and into Wednesday as well, regularly checking in with their prayer circle associates. According to David, Joan became increasingly verbally abusive and aggressive as time went on. By Thursday, January 28, Joan's restlessness had worsened to the point that she refused to stay seated and resisted the group's prayers. In response, Ralph suggested they tie her feet to wooden planks to prevent her from moving around and making what he described as satanic gestures.
来到安特卫普。抵达房产后，他觉得那里的气氛就像是一场“上帝与撒旦之间的属灵之战”。他和拉尔夫、莉安一起祈祷并宣读圣经。三人的努力持续了一整天，一直延续到周三，并定期与他们的祈祷圈同伴保持联系。据大卫说，随着时间的推移，琼变得越来越具有言语攻击性和侵略性。到了1月28日星期星期四，琼的焦躁不安恶化到她拒绝保持坐姿并抗拒集体祈祷的地步。作为回应，拉尔夫建议将她的脚绑在木板上，以防止她四处走动并做出他所描述的撒旦手势。
They also began depriving Joan of food and water as a way of starving the demons inside her. When she complained of her hunger and thirst, they would pray even louder to drown out her cries. Their questioning of Joan persisted, and if she didn't provide satisfactory replies, they slapped her face as a means of telling her, in Ralph's words, Come on, give us an answer. On a couple of occasions, Ralph became distressed at witnessing the torment his wife was enduring, including the bruises that had formed on her skin. When he voiced his concerns that this could not be God's will, Leanne and David pointed out to Ralph that it wasn't his wife they were physically battling,
他们还开始剥夺琼的食物和水，以此来饿死她体内的恶魔。当她抱怨饥饿和口渴时，他们会祈祷得更大声来掩盖她的哭喊声。他们对琼的质问仍在继续，如果她没有给出满意的答复，他们就会扇她耳光，用拉尔夫的话说，这是一种告诉她的方式：“来吧，给我们一个答案。”有几次，拉尔夫看到妻子正在经受的折磨以及她皮肤上形成的瘀青，感到十分痛苦。当他表达担忧，认为这不可能是上帝的旨意时，莉安和大卫向拉尔夫指出，他们肉体上与之搏斗的并不是他的妻子，
but a demonic presence. They reassured him that they were, quote, Not harming Joan in any way, we were just dealing with the evil spirit. Nevertheless, the group were at a loss as to why they couldn't see any improvement in Joan's well being despite the growing intensity of their deliverance. Lear advised them over the phone that they would need to call for more reinforcements if the demons still remained by Saturday. Throughout the exorcism, the group had also been consulting fellow prayer circle attendee Kathleen Nusky over the phone. Like Lear Clugston, Kathleen lived in rainbow and felt it was her obligation to assist with prayers and guidance. In the face of the group's continued failure to
而是一个恶魔般的存在。他们安慰他说：“我们绝没有以任何方式伤害琼，我们只是在对付邪灵。”然而，尽管释放仪式的强度不断增加，但看到琼的健康状况没有丝毫改善，这群人还是感到束手无策。莉亚通过电话建议他们，如果到周六恶魔仍然没有离开，他们就需要呼叫更多的增援。在驱魔过程中，该组织还通过电话咨询了祈祷圈的另一位成员凯瑟琳·努斯基（Kathleen Nusky）。像莉亚·克卢格斯滕一样，凯瑟琳住在雷恩博，觉得协助祈祷和指导是自己的义务。面对该组织一再未能
exercise Joan's demons, Kathleen suggested that her son, 22-year-old Matthew Paul Nusky, join them. Matthew lived nearly 400 kilometers away in the Melbourne suburb of Warrandyte and was employed as an assistant greenkeeper at a golf course. He had never participated in a deliverance before that Kathleen advised that he was particularly sensitive to the message of God and the presence of evil, having previously detected demons that resided in a house that he lived in. When Saturday, January 30, dawned with no perceivable change in Joan, Kathleen called her son and he agreed to make the long drive to Antwerp.
驱除琼身上的恶魔，凯瑟琳建议她的儿子、22岁的马修·保罗·努斯基（Matthew Paul Nusky）加入他们。马修住在近400公里外的墨尔本沃兰蒂特（Warrandyte）郊区，在一家高尔夫球场担任助理绿化工。他在此之前从未参加过释放仪式，但凯瑟琳建议说，他对上帝的信息和邪恶的存在特别敏感，因为他以前曾探测到自己住过的房子里有恶魔存在。1月30日星期六黎明时分，琼的状况依然没有明显改变，凯瑟琳打电话给儿子，马修同意长途驱车前往安特卫普。
It was another hot day, with the temperature reaching 40 degrees by noon when Matthew Paul Nusky pulled up to the property. In anticipation of his arrival, the group had removed all of the kitchen's furniture with the exception of a single chair that Joan was restrained in. Her stockings had been used to tie her feet to wooden planks that had been nailed together. She had barely had anything to eat or drink for days. Matthew later said that when he entered the room, Joan was unable to look at him, which he attributed to her detecting the presence of Jesus in him. As they began the day's deliverance, Matthew blessed some olive oil and anointed those present
那又是一个炎热的日子，当马修·保罗·努斯基将车停在房产前时，中午的气温已达到40度。为了迎接他的到来，这群人搬走了厨房里除了琼被捆绑的那张椅子以外的所有家具。她的长筒袜被用来将双脚绑在钉在一起的木板上。她已经好几天几乎没有吃喝了。马修后来回忆说，当他进入房间时，琼无法直视他，他将此归因于琼感知到了他体内耶稣的存在。当他们开始当天的释放仪式时，马修祝福了一些橄榄油并用它膏抹在场的人，
with it, before running around the exterior of the house seven times, holding up a 30cm square sheet of cling film in an attempt to prevent evil spirits from entering. He then decided they needed to destroy items that Joan loved, as they were shrines and altars for her devil worship. Ralph and David used a hammer to smash Joan's porcelain ornaments, jewellery and devasas, while Matthew ripped out the flowers in her beloved garden and greenhouse. Once Matthew had prepared for the exorcism, he re-entered the kitchen and said to Joan, in the name of Jesus, I demand you to sit down, while the other three attempted to pin her down. Joan was distressed and struggled against them with what they perceived as an inhuman strength.
然后围着房屋外侧跑了七次，手里拿着一张30厘米见方的保鲜膜，试图阻止邪灵进入。接着，他决定必须摧毁琼喜爱物品，因为这些是她崇拜魔鬼的神龛和祭坛。拉尔夫和大卫用锤子砸碎了琼的瓷器装饰品、首饰和花瓶，而马修则拔掉了她心爱的花园和温室里的花朵。一旦马修准备好驱魔，他重新走进厨房，对琼说：“奉耶稣的名，我命令你坐下，”而另外三人则试图将她按倒。琼感到痛苦并以他们认为不属于人类的力量进行反抗。
Over several hours she was repeatedly interrogated, while Leanne pressed forcefully against her stomach, abdomen and chest, in an effort to push out the demons that were inside her. David held Joan in a head block and deprived her eyes open with his fingers, so that she had to look at Matthew while he preached, saying over and over. In the precious name of the Lord Jesus, released this woman. The slapping continued, with Joan receiving approximately 20 hits to the face. At one stage, her jaw was wrenched open in an effort to remove a demon. Leanne continued to call her husband, John, and Lea Clugston, keeping them up to date with
在几个小时的时间里，她屡次遭到审讯，莉安则用力按压她的胃部、腹部和胸部，试图将她体内的恶魔挤出来。大卫用手臂夹住琼的头部，并用手指撑开她的眼睛，迫使她在马修布道时看着他，马修一遍又一遍地重复着：“奉主耶稣宝贵的精神，释放这个女人。”耳光还在继续，琼的脸部大约挨了20记重击。某个阶段，为了赶走恶魔，她的下巴被强行掰开。莉安继续给她的丈夫约翰和莉亚·克卢格斯滕打电话，让他们了解最新情况并听从他们的指示。通过对琼的盘问，该组织认为他们已经认出其中一个恶魔是“群鬼”（legion），这是一个耶稣曾经从被附身男子身上赶走的强大灵魂。他们声称，当被群鬼控制时，琼会表现出男性的个性。这与另一个名为“小琼尼”（Baby Joanie）或“小公主琼”（Baby Princess Joan）的灵魂形成了对比，后者用孩子气的声音说话，并详细讲述了她小时候所遭受的性虐待。几个小时后，该组织认为他们已经成功驱逐了许多恶魔，包括小公主琼和另一个像猪一样的恶魔，但“群鬼”和另一个强大的男性灵魂仍然留着，藏在琼的子宫里。下午四点，她被
proceedings and following their directions. Through their questioning of Joan, the group believed they had identified one of the demons as a legion, a powerful spirit that Jesus had once cast from a possessed man. They claimed that when controlled by legion, Joan adopted a masculine persona. This contrasted with another spirit called Baby Joanie, or Baby Princess Joan, who spoke in a childlike voice and detailed sexual abuses that had been inflicted on her as a young girl. After several hours, the group believed they had successfully driven out a number of demons, including Baby Princess Joan and another that resembled a pig, but that legion and another strong male spirit remained, hiding in Joan's womb. At four o'clock in the afternoon, she was
转移到卧室，进行驱魔的最后阶段。一到卧室，几个人轮流坐在琼身上，推压她的胃、胸、脖子和头部，以逼出最后两个恶魔，他们将大部分注意力集中在她的腹部，然后向上移动身体。到下午4点30分左右，他们将注意力集中在琼的脖子上，用力按摩，此时她突然全身战栗，发出一声响亮的呻吟，随后一动不动。在场的人将此解读为恶魔离去的表现，马修宣布邪灵终于被战胜了。正当其他人开始庆祝时，拉尔夫注意到妻子不再呼吸，便摸她的手腕测脉搏。在没有摸到脉搏后，
moved to her bedroom for the exorcism's final stage. Once in the bedroom, the group took it in turns to sit on Joan and push on her stomach, chest, neck, and head to force the final two demons out, concentrating most of their attention on her abdomen before moving up her body. By around 4.30pm, they were focusing on Joan's neck, firmly massaging it, when she suddenly shuddered and emitted a loud groan before falling still. Those present interpreted this as the demons leaving her, and Matthew declared that the evil spirits had finally been defeated. As the others began to celebrate, Ralph noticed that his wife was no longer breathing and felt her wrist for a pulse. Failing to find one,
他向其他人发出警报，众人尝试通过人工呼吸来救活琼。失败后，马修安慰大家说，进入这种状态对于刚刚经历过成功释放仪式的人来说是正常的。在通过电话咨询莉亚·克卢格斯滕后，马修宣布琼将在第二天早上恢复健康并苏醒。他吩咐其他人为她祈祷，然后离开房产去处理其他事情。剩下的三个人给琼的尸体盖上一条被子，开始唱起颂扬上帝胜利的赞美诗。第二天，即1月31日星期日，琼并没有像承诺的那样醒来。莉安·赖兴巴赫打电话给莉亚·克卢格斯滕和凯瑟琳·努斯基，两人同意前来房产，
he alerted the others, and they attempted to revive Joan via mouth to mouth resuscitation. When this failed, Matthew reassured the group that entering a state such as this was normal for an individual who had just undergone a successful deliverance. After consulting with Leia Klugsten by telephone, Matthew announced that Joan would arise by the next morning restored to perfect health. He told the others to pray over her, then departed the property to attend to other matters. The remaining trio pulled a quilt over Joan's body and began to sing songs of God's victory. The following day, Sunday, January 31, Joan had failed to wake as promised. Leanne Reichenbach phoned Leia Klugsten and Kathleen Nusky, who agreed to visit the property
以便亲手按在琼身上并为她祈祷。当这几位女性到达时，她们将手按在琼的前额上，命令她站起来并走路，但无济于事。莉亚重复了这个过程三次，然后于下午离开。农场里的人继续守夜并唱赞美诗，而在家里，莉亚为关于她在沃尔玛住宅看到的情况的进一步指示祈祷。周一早上，在与大嫂商议后，莉亚相信自己收到了另一个相当世俗的信息，指示她报警。
so they could lay hands on Joan and pray for her in person. When the women arrived, they pressed their hands on Joan's forehead and commanded her to rise up and to walk, to no avail. Leia repeated the process three times before leaving in the afternoon. Those at the farm continued to hold vigil and sing hymns, while at home, Leia prayed for further instructions regarding what she had seen at the Volma residence. On Monday morning, after consulting with her sister-in-law, Leia believed she had received another rather worldly message, telling her to call the authorities. The
高级警员杰弗里·亚内特（Jeffrey Yarnett）于2月1日星期一在杰帕拉（Geparat）镇值班，当时接到当地路德宗牧师打来的电话，请求派遣一名警官前往26公里以南的安特卫普的一处房产。牧师刚刚被传唤到那里，对自已所看到的情景感到不安。当亚内特警官于下午2点左右抵达沃尔玛的农舍时，他受到了一个自称大卫·克林格的光头男子的迎接，对方说道：“说来话长。”走进屋里，警察看到拉尔夫·沃尔玛和莉安·赖兴巴赫坐在厨房桌旁，莉安正在大声朗读圣经，拉尔夫则用记号笔标出与复活相关的段落。沿着走廊继续往里走，
senior constable Jeffrey Yarnett was on duty in the town of Geparat on Monday, February 1, when a call came through from the local Lutheran minister requesting an officer's presence at a property in Antwerp, 26 kilometers south. The minister had just been summoned there himself, and was disturbed by what he had found. When Constable Yarnett arrived at the Volma's farmhouse at around 2 p.m., he was greeted by a balding man who identified himself as David Klingner and stated, It's a long story. Entering the house, the policemen saw Ralph Volma and Leanne Reichenbach seated at the kitchen table, Leanne reading aloud from a Bible and Ralph using a marker to highlight passages relating to resurrection. Continuing down a hallway to the
亚内特警官看到一张床躺着一具面部和手臂有明显瘀伤、处于高度腐烂状态的女尸。尸体上聚集了苍蝇和蛆虫，其下方的床垫上有一个巨大的污渍，房间里弥漫着恶臭。亚内特警官估计这名女子已经死了好几天了。回到厨房，他看到拉尔夫仍在阅读圣经，并注意到有一种“奇怪的平静气氛”。亚内特警官询问拉尔夫是否会为妻子操办葬礼，但拉尔夫回答说不会有葬礼，他即将见证最大的奇迹，因为琼很快就会活着走出
bedroom, Constable Yarnett saw a female body with noticeable facial and arm bruising in an advanced state of decomposition lying on the bed. Flyers and maggots had gathered on the body, under which there was an enormous stain on the mattress, and a foul odor permeated the room. Constable Yarnett estimated the woman had been dead for several days. Upon returning to the kitchen, he saw Ralph still reading his Bible and noticed there was, quote, a strange atmosphere of calm. Constable Yarnett queried Ralph as to whether he would be making funeral arrangements for his wife, but Ralph responded that there wouldn't be a funeral, and he was about to witness the greatest miracle, as Joan would soon walk out of the
卧室，并拥有完全恢复健康的身体。震惊之selective下，亚内特警官没有再做评论，并呼叫了支援。拉尔夫继续阅读他的圣经。大卫告诉其他赶到的警官，琼的死是因为该组织在实体上“驱除”她体内的恶魔。当被问及琼的身体为何会有如此多的瘀伤时，他解释说恶魔赋予了她巨大的力量，必须被强行按住。凶杀案组安排将尸体运往墨尔本进行尸检。当天下午，拉尔夫、莉安和大卫都被带到霍舍姆警察局接受正式讯问。他们在那里接受了当地警方几个小时的盘问，之后凶杀案
bedroom alive with a completely restored body. Shocked, Constable Yarnett made no further comment and called for backup. Ralph returned to reading his Bible. David told other responding officers that Joan had died as the group had been physically reading the demonic spirits from her. When queried as to how Joan's body had become so bruised, he explained that the demons had given her enormous strength and she had to be forcefully held down. The homicide squad arranged to have the body taken to Melbourne for a post-mortem examination. That afternoon, Ralph, Leanne, and David were all taken to Horsham police station to be formally questioned. They were interviewed for several hours by local police, before homicide squad
侦探从墨尔本赶来，开始了第二阶段的讯问。在供述中，拉尔夫·富尔默声称他在驱魔期间发现了关于妻子的令人不安的事情，例如她的父母在她出生时献祭了另外两个孩子，并在她三岁时以撒旦的名义为她施洗。在这个所谓的洗礼之后，她对于那些崇拜撒旦的人来说被称为“小公主琼”。琼的家人在她死后避开了公众聚光灯，否认了这些说法。拉尔夫还说，琼对进入湖滨精神健康医院感到非常痛苦，因此他向她保证，她永远不必重返精神科治疗。
detectives arrived from Melbourne and commenced the second phase of interviews. In his account, Ralph Fulmer claimed that he had discovered disturbing things about his wife during the exorcism, such as that her parents had sacrificed two of their other children at birth and had baptized her in the name of Satan when she was three years old. After this alleged baptism, she became known as Baby Princess Joan to those who worshipped Satan. Joan's family, who avoided the public spotlight following her death, denied these claims. Ralph also said that Joan had been very distraught by her admission to Lakeside Mental Health Hospital, so he had made her a promise that she would never have to return to psychiatric care.
这也是为妻子寻求神圣介入而非医疗干预的一个因素。他表示，他的同道信徒莉安·赖兴巴赫和大卫·克林格比他更敏感于上帝的声音，所以在从琼身上提取信息时，他大体上听从了他们的领导。关于对琼施加的虐待和伤害，拉尔夫坚信她不会感受到任何肉体痛苦。“这会深深伤害我的妻子，但那不是我的妻子。我们不再是在和我的妻子打交道。这就是重点。你看，我绝不允许这种事情发生在我的妻子身上。你不能相信那。她不是我的妻子。她是一个需要被对付的邪灵。”
This had been a factor in seeking divine intervention for his wife instead of medical attention. He stated that his fellow worshippers, Leanne Reichenbach and David Klingner, were more sensitive to the voice of God than he was, so for the most part he followed their lead when it came to extracting information from Joan. In regards to the mistreatment and injuries inflicted against Joan, Ralph insisted she wouldn't have felt any physical pain. It would have hurt my wife terribly, but it wasn't my wife. We weren't dealing with my wife anymore. This is the whole point. See, I wouldn't allow anything like that to happen to my wife. You can't believe that. She wasn't my wife. She was an evil spirit that needed to be dealt with.
这就是他为妻子寻求神圣干预而不是医疗救助的一个因素。他表示，他的同修莱安·赖肯巴赫（Leanne Reichenbach）和大卫·克林格（David Klingner）比他更能倾听上帝的声音，因此在从琼那里获取信息时，他基本上听从了他们的主张。关于对琼的虐待和伤害，拉尔夫坚称她不会感到任何身体上的痛苦。这本来会深深伤害我的妻子，但那已经不是我的妻子了。我们面对的不再是我的妻子。这就是全部的重点。你看，我绝不允许那种事发生在我妻子身上。你不会相信的。她不是我的妻子。她是一个需要被对付的邪灵。
Despite having witnessed the decomposition of her body, he remained adamant that Joan would be revived, stating his expectation that God would provide her with a new body and, quote, do a complete resurrection job. Leanne Reichenbach expressed her surprise that Joan had died due to the group pressing on her neck, saying that they believed they were doing what was necessary to do. She told police she'd been involved in deliverances for 18 months, but had never encountered anything like Joan's case before. David Klingner acknowledged that while it would have been appropriate to call an ambulance for
尽管亲眼目睹了琼的遗体开始腐烂，他依然坚信琼会复活，并表示他期望上帝会给她一副新身体，并“完成一次彻底的复活”。莉安·赖兴巴赫对琼因为群体压迫其颈部而死表示惊讶，称他们当时认为自己在做必要的事。她告诉警方，她从事驱魔工作已有18个月，但从未遇到过像琼这样棘手的案件。大卫·克林格承认，虽然从世俗的角度来看，为
Joan, quote, in worldly terms, the group had been dealing with a spiritual matter. He said God had provided him a message that the case would receive worldwide attention, leading to those who had performed the exorcism being criminally charged and possibly imprisoned. In response to these consequences, God would return Joan to life, and, quote, show he is victorious in this day and age. The three individuals were permitted to return home in the early hours of Tuesday, February 2. Later that day, detectives visited the Valmer property and filmed Ralph as he took the monitor of the homestead, providing a narrative of the exorcism and pointing out where particular
琼叫救护车是合适的，但该群体当时处理的是一桩精神层面的事务。他说，上帝向他传达了一个信息：此案将受到全球关注，导致进行驱魔的人遭到刑事指控并可能入狱。作为对这些后果的回应，上帝将使琼起死回生，并“展现他在这个时代的胜利”。2月2日星期二凌晨，这三名涉案人员被允许回家。当天晚些时候，侦探们造访了瓦尔默的房产，并拍下了拉尔夫取下宅基地监控的画面，他一边讲述驱魔的过程，一边指出特定
events had taken place. An autopsy determined that the thyroid cartilage in Joan's neck had been fractured due to the amount of pressure that the perpetrators had applied, and she died of cardiac arrest. Within two days of police finding her body, both Australian and international media outlets were reporting on the bizarre case. Ralph openly spoke to the journalists who turned up at his property, sharing all of the details about the exorcism. In one newspaper report published on Wednesday, February 3, he described the moment that his wife died, quote, There was a great noise of hissing, screaming and groaning. As the noise died down, I looked at
事件发生的地点。尸检确定，琼的颈部甲状软骨因施暴者施加的压力过大而骨折，死因是心脏骤停。在警方发现她尸体的两天内，澳大利亚和国际各大媒体就开始报道这起离奇的案件。拉尔夫公开与出现在他家门口的记者交谈，分享了有关驱魔的所有细节。在2月3日星期三出版的一份报纸报道中，他描述了妻子去世时的情景：“传出了巨大的嘶嘶声、尖叫声和呻吟声。随着声音减弱，我看着
her eyes and I saw the light leave them. He explained that her death wasn't reported because they had received messages that the Lord would raise her up. Joan's funeral was scheduled for Friday, February 5, less than a week after her death. Ralph informed the media he knew with absolute certainty that she would be resurrected before her body was laid to rest, stating, She will tell God's story to people around the world and get sinners to repent. He was eager that the media share the story and invited journalists to attend so that they could witness the miracle for themselves. The modest service was held in Horsham at the Salvation Army Hall where Joan and Ralph had occasionally worshipped. Roughly 60 of
她的眼睛，看到光芒从她眼中消失了。”他解释说，之所以没有报告她的死讯，是因为他们收到了主将使其复活的信息。琼的葬礼定于2月5日星期五举行，距离她去世不到一周。拉尔夫向媒体通报说，他绝对确信她会在遗体下葬前复活，并表示：“她将向世界各地的人们讲述上帝的故事，让罪人悔改。”他渴望媒体报道这个故事，并邀请记者出席，以便他们能亲眼见证奇迹。这场简朴的追悼会在霍舍姆的救世军大厅举行，琼和拉尔夫以前偶尔在那里做礼拜。
Joan's friends and fellow churchgoers attended, but her family were absent, reportedly too distressed by the manner of her death to be there. As many as 30 journalists and photographers, as well as Horsham police officers, monitored proceedings. Salvation Army Captain Colin Corkery presided over the service, stating, In 10 years of ministry, we have never known any experience to be so traumatic. In the two years we have known Ralph and Joan, we have known them to be gentle, simple and caring people. He cautioned against alone ranger exorcists who operated outside the bounds of churches. Lorna Keeman, her Salvation Army sister, said Joan's legacy would be that of a happy,
大约有60位琼的朋友和同教友出席了葬礼，但她的家属缺席了，据报道是因为对她死亡的方式感到太过悲痛而无法出席。多达30名记者、摄影师以及霍舍姆警方监控了整个仪式。救世军上尉科林·科克里主持了仪式，并表示：“在我们十年的牧师生涯中，从未经历过如此创伤性的事件。在认识拉尔夫和琼的两年里，我们知道他们是温和、单纯和富有爱心的人。”他警告人们不要独自进行游离于教会界限之外的驱魔活动。她的救世军姐妹洛娜·基曼说，琼留给世人的将是一位快乐、
caring, loving woman who walked with the Jesus. Following the ceremony, the casket was taken to Horsham Cemetery for burial, where curious spectators gathered around the perimeter awaiting the alleged miracle Ralph had promised. After a Bible passage was shared, Joan's coffin was slowly lowered into its grave, and Ralph closed his eyes, tilting his head to the sky to pray. When the casket touched the ground, Ralph began sobbing for the first time, turning to his son's for support as he finally realized Joan was gone. He willingly spoke with reporters after the burial, theorizing that perhaps Joan
关爱他人、充满爱心并与耶稣同行的女性的形象。仪式结束后，灵柩被运往霍舍姆公墓安葬，好奇的旁观者聚集在四周，等待拉尔夫承诺的所谓奇迹。在分享了一段圣经经文后，琼的棺材被缓缓放入墓穴，拉尔夫闭上眼睛，仰头向天祈祷。当棺材触地时，拉尔夫生平第一次放声大哭，转而向儿子们寻求支持，因为他终于意识到琼已经离他而去。葬礼后，他欣然接受了记者的采访，推测或许琼
hadn't wanted to return because she loved heaven so much. David Klinger also spoke with the press, stating that he had nothing to hide, and if the police wanted to speak with him again, quote, then I guess they'll find me. He revealed that he and John Reichenbach had already performed a deliverance on another woman just four days after Joan's death, but this one had been a success. Some time after the funeral, Ralph moved in with the Reichenbachs, helping out on the couple's farm and taking care of their children, while one of his sons took over the property at Antwerp. The Reichenbachs prayer circle disbanded, but they and Ralph maintained their faith, regularly attending services at another church in Horsham.
是因为太留恋天堂才不想回来。大卫·克林格也接受了媒体采访，称自己没什么好隐瞒的，如果警察想再次找他谈谈，“那我想他们能找到我”。他透露，在琼死后仅仅四天，他和约翰·赖兴巴赫就已经为另一名妇女成功实施了一次驱魔。葬礼后不久，拉尔夫搬去和赖兴巴赫一家同住，在两人的农场帮忙并照顾他们的孩子，而他的一个儿子则接管了安特卫普的房产。赖兴巴赫一家的祈祷圈解散了，但他们和拉尔夫依然坚定信仰，定期去霍舍姆的另一座教堂参加礼拜。
Police prepared a report for the coroner, and three months after Joan's death, Ralph Fulmer, Leanne Reichenbach, David Klinger, and Matthew Nusky were all charged with manslaughter. All four received bail and were ordered to face a three-day committal hearing in September. On Monday, September 13, the four defendants, each carrying a Bible, filed into Horsham Magistrates Court. Two religious experts, a Baptist theologian and a Catholic church official, gave evidence that while they believed in demonic possession, such cases were rare. An improved understanding of mental health had led them to believe many so-called possessions of the past had been misdiagnosed psychological disorders.
警方为验尸官准备了一份报告。在琼死后三个月，拉尔夫·富尔默、莉安·赖兴巴赫、大卫·克林格和马修·努斯基均被指控过失杀人罪。四人均获得保释，并被命令于9月出庭接受为期三天的预审聆讯。9月13日星期一，四名被告每人手持一本圣经，鱼贯进入霍舍姆地方法院。两名宗教专家——一名浸信会神学家和一名天主教会官员——出庭作证称，尽管他们相信恶魔附身，但此类案例非常罕见。对心理健康更深入的理解使他们相信，过去许多所谓的“附身”其实是被误诊的心理障碍。
Joan's mental health diagnosis two years earlier was relayed to the court, and how the Reichenbachs history with exorcisms had led to them being expelled from their church. On the hearing's second day, Lea Clugston took the stand, telling the court that she had regularly consulted the defendants throughout the exorcism, and while she had never met Joan, God had repeatedly confirmed that she was possessed. Lea stated that after visiting the property on January 31 and laying hands on Joan's deceased body, she alerted the local minister after much prayer on the matter. At various stages, she would shut her and interrupt her own testimony to channel the voice of God, exclaiming, I'm sorry, that is God speaking, yes.
琼两年前的心理健康诊断结果在法庭上被披露，以及赖兴巴赫一家的驱魔历史如何导致他们被教会开除。在听证会的第二天，莉娅·克卢格斯顿出庭作证，她告诉法庭，在整个驱魔过程中，她曾多次向被告咨询；尽管她从未见过琼，但上帝一再向她证实琼确实被附身了。莉娅表示，在1月31日造访该房产并把手放在琼的遗体上后，经过多番祈祷，她将此事警示了当地牧师。在不同的阶段，她会停下来打断自己的证词，以传达上帝的声音，惊呼道：“我很抱歉，那是上帝在说话，是的。”
The pathologist who performed to Joan's autopsy testified that it was highly probable that her cardiac arrest was a result of the pressure the defendants had placed on her neck. However, as Joan died five minutes or longer after the force was applied, her cause of death could not be determined with absolute certainty, and there was insufficient evidence to prove it was a consequence of Joan's death. On Thursday, September 16, magistrate Tim McDonald conceded that although the four defendants had in all likelihood contributed to Joan's death, his decision was to drop all of the charges, stating, I find the prosecution has not produced enough evidence of sufficient weight for a jury to find the cardiac arrest was caused by application of pressure on the neck
实施琼尸检的病理学家作证说，她的心脏骤停极有可能是被告施加在她颈部的压力所致。然而，由于琼在施力后五分钟或更长时间才死亡，其确凿死因无法完全确定，且没有充分证据证明这是琼死亡的必然结果。9月16日星期四，地方法官蒂姆·麦克唐纳承认，尽管四名被告极有可能导致了琼的死亡，但他做出的决定是撤销所有指控，并表示：“我认为控方没有提供足够分量的证据，以支持陪审团认定死者心脏骤停是由对其颈部施压引起的。”
of the deceased. Though surprised by the magistrate's decision, all four defendants were pleased with the result. They sobbed, clapped, and embraced their relatives, and newspaper photographers captured some of them smiling broadly as they left the courthouse. All four remained staunchly committed to their faith and felt vindicated by the ruling, with Ralph Fulmer telling journalists, God's will has been done, and I just praise and rejoice in the Lord. He gave media interviews the following day in which he remarked that God had been on trial, telling Melbourne newspaper the Sunday age that he disagreed with the finding that he and the others had most likely contributed to Joan's death, but that the magistrate had been as understanding as
尽管对地方法官的决定感到意外，但四名被告对结果都很满意。他们喜极而泣、鼓掌并与亲属拥抱，报社摄影师捕捉到了他们离开法院时灿烂的笑容。四人依然坚守信仰，并对这一判决感到沉冤得雪。拉尔夫·富尔默对记者表示：“上帝的旨意已经成就，我唯有赞美和颂扬主。”他在次日接受媒体采访时表示，受审的其实是上帝，他在接受墨尔本报纸《星期日时代报》采访时表示，他不同意他和其余人极有可能导致琼死亡的裁决，但地方法官已经尽其所能地给予了理解。
he could be. When asked what he would do if he had his time over, Ralph said he would still choose to exercise Joan. Quote, I still maintain that she was possessed and it was God's will to take her home. The broader community did not share the defendant's views and were deeply disturbed by the ruling. Joan's death had sent shockwaves through Antwerp and the wider Wimmera region. Although many in the area are identified as religious, the majority of them attended a mainstream church and felt that the legal system was not holding extremists accountable for their actions. A number of locals aired their grievances to the media, with longtime Antwerp resident Ivan Pollak telling the Sunday age newspaper, Everyone reckons we can do anything to our
当被问及如果时间可以倒流他会怎么做时，拉尔夫表示他依然会选择为琼驱魔。“我依然坚持认为她被附身了，带她回家是上帝的旨意。”更广泛的社区并不认同被告的观点，对这一裁决感到深为不安。琼的死在安特卫普和更广泛的维默拉地区引起了强烈震动。尽管该地区的许多人被认作有宗教信仰，但他们大多数去主流教堂，并认为法律体系没有让极端分子为他们的行为承担责任。许多当地人向媒体倾诉不满，安特卫普的老居民伊万·波拉克对《星期日时代报》说：“每个人都认为我们现在对自己的
wives now and get away with it, as long as we preach the gospel. Nobody's happy about it. Everybody's disgusted. Absolutely. Church spokespeople pointed out that this sort of event was the risk people took when taking matters into their own hands, rather than calling in a religious authority. The Royal Australian and New Zealand College of Psychiatrists called for a review of the case. Mental health workers expressed concern that vulnerable people may be targeted for recruitment by unconventional churches, as some people suffering from schizophrenia believed themselves to be possessed by demons. Professor Graham Burroughs, chairman of the Mental Health Foundation, told The Age, If people have a psychiatric disease, they should receive appropriate treatments,
妻子做什么都可以逃脱惩罚，只要我们宣讲福音。没有人对此感到高兴。所有人都感到恶心，绝对如此。”教会发言人指出，当人们选择自己动手而不是求助于宗教权威时，这种事件就是他们必须承担的风险。澳大利亚和新西兰皇家精神科医务人员学院呼吁对该案进行审查。心理健康工作者表达了他们的担忧，即弱势群体可能会成为非常规教会招募的目标，因为一些患有精神分裂症的人认为自己被恶魔附身了。精神健康基金会主席格雷厄姆·巴罗斯教授对《时代报》说：“如果人们患有精神疾病，他们应该得到适当的治疗，
and exorcism is not one of them. In the wake of the public outrage, Victoria's director of public prosecutions continued to look into the case. After reviewing the evidence with assistance from at least four legal advisors, the charges against the four acquitted were reinstated. On February 14, 1994, Ralph Vollmer, Leanne Reichenbach, David Klingner, and Matthew Nusky were served with notices to stand trial for manslaughter, unlawful imprisonment, and recklessly causing serious injury. Though the exorcism of Joan Vollmer had lasted for over a week, the charges only related to their actions between noon and 4.30 pm on Saturday, January 30, 1993, the hours leading up to her death. All four entered pleas of not guilty
而驱魔绝不是其中之一。”在公众的愤怒爆发之后，维多利亚州的公共检察总长继续调查此案。在至少四名法律顾问的协助下审查了证据后，针对四名被无罪释放者的指控被恢复了。1994年2月14日，拉尔夫·沃尔默、莉安·赖兴巴赫、大卫·克林格和马修·努斯基收到了出庭受审的传票，罪名是过失杀人、非法拘禁和鲁莽造成严重伤害。尽管对琼·沃尔默的驱魔持续了一个多星期，但指控仅涉及他们在1993年1月30日星期六中午到下午4点30分（即她死前几个小时）之间的行为。四人均做出了无罪抗辩
and were granted bail once again. The trial commenced on Monday, October 17, 1994, and was a sensational event for the small, single-story courthouse. A jury of five women and seven men were sworn in, and dozens of journalists and spectators oversaw the proceedings. Rather than dismiss the defendant's beliefs as outlandish, the prosecution's approach was to bring in their own religious experts to testify that the behavior of the four accused did not align with mainstream Christianity. The jury was told about Joan's 1990 diagnosis of anxiety, depression, schizophrenia, and hypomania, her decision to cease taking medication, and her subsequent decline after attending the Charismatic Christian Convention two years later.
并再次获得了保释。审判于1994年10月17日星期星期一正式开始，对于这个小型的单层法院来说，这是一场轰动一时的事件。由五名女性和七名男性组成的陪审团宣誓就职，数十名记者和旁观者监督了整个诉讼过程。控方的策略并非将被告的信仰斥为荒诞，而是请来他们自己的宗教专家出庭作证，证明四名被告的行为不符合主流基督教。陪审团听取了关于琼在1990年被诊断患有焦虑症、抑郁症、精神分裂症和轻度躁狂症的情况，她决定停止服药，以及两年后在参加灵恩基督教大会后病情随之恶化的情况。
The video shot by investigators at the Vollmer property was also shown, revealing the stockings and boards used to restrain Joan, as well as Joan's destroyed belongings and garden. It emerged during the trial that Ralph had not informed Joan's family about her cause of death. Joan's brother-in-law, Neville, who was married to her sister Dorothy, gave evidence about a phone call he'd received from Ralph three days after Joan's death, letting them know that an autopsy was being performed. When asked how her death had occurred, Ralph merely said, she died slowly. The couple were left to learn the details from media reports.
调查人员在沃尔默家中拍摄的录像也在庭上播放，展示了用于束缚琼的丝袜和木板，以及琼被毁坏的物品和花园。庭审中还透露，拉尔夫并没有将琼的死因告知她的家族。琼的姐夫内维尔（娶了她的姐姐多萝西）提供了一份证词，关于他在琼死后三天接到拉尔夫打来的电话，拉尔夫在电话里告知他们正在对遗体进行尸检。当被问及她的死是如何发生时，拉尔夫仅冷淡地说：“她死得很慢。”这对夫妇只能通过媒体报道来了解详细情况。
A psychiatrist who had treated Joan at Lakeside Mental Health Hospital provided background on her psychiatric history. A senior Catholic official gave evidence that the number of exorcisms performed had significantly declined over the years, likely due to ongoing advances in the mental health field. He also stated that an exorcism typically involved prayer and possibly laying hands on the head of the possessed individual, nothing like the treatment that Joan had been subjected to. Though none of the accused took the stand, Leanne's husband John Reichenbach gave evidence. He claimed that Joan had been possessed by multiple spirits and described how she had appeared and behaved when under the influence of the entities he identified as Legion and Baby
曾治疗过琼的精神病医生在湖滨心理健康医院提供了有关她精神病史的背景信息。一位高级天主教会官员作证说，多年来实施的驱魔数量已显著下降，这可能是由于精神健康领域的不断进步。他还表示，驱魔通常涉及祈祷，并可能将手放在被附身者的头上，这与琼所遭受的待遇完全不同。尽管没有被告出庭作证，但莉安的丈夫约翰·赖兴巴赫出庭作证。他声称琼被多个恶灵附身，并描述了她在受到他称为“军团”和“宝贝”的实体影响时的外表和行为。
Princess Joan. He also asserted that they had known Joan was possessed because she revealed information about the exorcists that she had no way of knowing. When Matthew Nusky had arrived at the farm, Joan said, 22, piss pot, which those present interpreted as a reference to his age and a problem he'd previously had with alcohol. Lea Clugsden was also called to testify and again declared God was speaking directly to her, just as she had at the committal hearing. David Klingner's defense attorney told the court that his client would have viewed not participating in the exorcism as, quote, a serious neglect of his duty. While Leanne Reichenbach's lawyer said exorcisms were not unlawful and none of her actions could have led to Joan's death.
公主琼。他还断言，他们知道琼被附身了，是因为她说出了关于驱魔人的信息，而这是她绝无可能知道的。当马修·努斯基到达农场时，琼说：“22岁，尿罐子”，在场的人将其解读为对他的年龄以及他以前酗酒问题的指代。莉娅·克卢格斯登也应传唤出庭作证，并再次宣称上帝直接对她说话，正如她在预审听证会上所做的那样。大卫·克林格的辩护律师告诉法庭，他的当事人会将不参与驱魔视为“严重玩忽职守”。而莉安·赖兴巴赫的律师则表示，驱魔并非违法，她的任何行为都不可能导致琼的死亡。
On Tuesday, October 25, Leanne tended a letter to the court justifying the group's actions. The letter stated that the group performing the exorcism knew that they were acting in God's will because he gave them confirmation that their actions were proper. Leanne also noted that only God knew why Joan had not been resurrected after her death and that some good had resulted from the situation because the story had, quote, gone worldwide to highlight the existence of a spiritual realm. Ralph Vollmers Barrister argued that his client was a reasonable person who had turned to his religious community after seeing no improvement in Joan following her release from hospital in 1990. When Joan seemed to recover shortly after Ralph prayed for her to get better,
10月25日星期二，莉安向法庭递交了一封信，为该团体的行为辩护。信中指出，实施驱魔的群体知道他们是在顺应上帝的意志，因为上帝给了他们确认，证明他们的行为是恰当的。莉安还指出，只有上帝才知道为什么琼死后没有复活，而且这种情况产生了一些积极的结果，因为这个故事“已经传遍全球，突显了精神世界的存在”。拉尔夫·沃尔默的辩护大律师辩称，他的当事人在1990年从医院出院后看到琼的病情没有改善，便转向了他的宗教社区，他是一个理智的人。当拉尔夫为琼祈祷康复后不久，琼似乎恢复了过来，
he attributed this to the power of prayer. The defense pointed to references to exorcisms in the Bible, saying their long tradition made demonic possession entirely reasonable to someone of faith. A psychologist called to give evidence about Ralph's personality and character said Ralph trusted the few friends he had implicitly. It had taken him more than a year to accept that his wife was deceased and wouldn't be returning. A month into the trial, the barrister representing Matthew Nusky requested to have the most serious charge against his client dropped. His barrister argued that the crown had failed to make a case for manslaughter against Matthew, who was now 24 and studying to be a missionary at the interdenominational college in Perth.
他将此归功于祈祷的力量。辩方指出了圣经中对驱魔的提及，称其悠久传统使得有信仰的人完全合乎情理地相信恶魔附身。一位被传唤就拉尔夫的个性和性格作证的心理学家说，拉尔夫盲目信任他仅有的几个朋友。他花了快一年的时间才接受他的妻子已经去世且不会再回来的事实。庭审进行了一个月后，代表马修·努斯基的大律师请求撤销对他当事人的最严重指控。他的大律师辩称，皇家检察署未能针对马修提出过失杀人指控。马修现在24岁，正在珀斯的跨教派学院学习成为一名传教士。
The trial judge, Justice Graham Crossley, agreed there was insufficient evidence to convict and instructed the jury to acquit Matthew of manslaughter. A week later, both sides gave their closing address. Prosecutor Peter Jones argued that Ralph should have recognized his wife required professional medical help, but instead, quote, common sense gave way to zealotry, which led to a volatile lexicism. He told the jury that the defendants had no right to confine Joan or assault her body, adding, they had no consideration for Christianity. They went right past that. They were on a frolic of their own and an unlawful frolic. The defense urged jurors to reflect on the evidence
审判长格雷厄姆·克罗斯利法官认同证据不足，并指示陪审团裁定马修过失杀人罪名不成立。一周后，双方发表了结案陈词。检察官彼得·琼斯辩称，拉尔夫本应认识到他的妻子需要专业的医疗帮助，但相反，“常识让位给狂热，从而导致了一场动荡的驱魔。”他告诉陪审团，被告无权拘禁琼或殴打她的身体，并补充道：“他们根本不考虑基督教。他们完全越界了。他们在进行一场属于他们自己的、非法的胡闹。”辩方敦促陪审团在没有偏见的情况下反思证据
without prejudice and set aside sensationalist media reports they might have read following Joan's death. They also pointed out that it was possible that Joan had died from an asthma attack or an epileptic fit, as the pathologist had not been able to determine the cause of death with absolute certainty. The jury had a difficult task ahead. While the local community wanted justice for Joan, exorcisms in and of themselves were not illegal, meaning they would have to consider whether the actions performed by the group during the ritual were unlawful and amounted to manslaughter. After a day's deliberation, the jury returned to deliver the verdict to late on Wednesday, November 30. They found Ralph Vollmer not guilty of manslaughter, but guilty of one
并将他们可能在琼死后读到的耸人听闻的媒体报道抛诸脑后。他们还指出，琼也可能是死于哮喘发作或癫痫发作，因为病理学家无法以绝对的确定性确定死因。陪审团面临着一项艰巨的任务。虽然当地社区希望为琼伸张正义，但驱魔本身并不违法，这意味着他们必须考虑该群体在仪式期间实施的行为是否非法并构成了过失杀人罪。经过一天的审议，陪审团于11月30日星期三晚些时候返回并宣读了裁决。他们裁定拉尔夫·沃尔默过失杀人罪名不成立，但犯有一项
count of recklessly causing serious injury and one count of false imprisonment. As per the judge's instructions, Matthew Nusky was acquitted of manslaughter, but convicted on one count of false imprisonment. Leanne Reichenbach and David Klingner were both convicted of false imprisonment and manslaughter, making them the only ones held directly responsible for killing Joan. When sentencing the perpetrators, Judge Crossley explained that they were not being sentenced for performing the exorcism, but for the undue force they had used against Joan, as the law did not allow excesses in the name of religion. He noted that regardless of whether Joan had suffered from a mental illness or been possessed by demons, the level of violence inflicted
鲁莽造成严重伤害罪和一项非法拘禁罪。根据法官的指示，马修·努斯基被判过失杀人罪名不成立，但犯有一项非法拘禁罪。莉安·赖兴巴赫和大卫·克林格均被判犯有非法拘禁罪和过失杀人罪，使他们成为仅有的对杀害琼承担直接责任的人。在对罪犯进行宣判时，克罗斯利法官解释说，对他们的判决不是因为他们进行了驱魔，而是因为他们对琼使用了过度的武力，因为法律不允许以宗教的名义进行过度行为。他指出，无论琼是患有精神疾病还是被恶魔附身，施加在她身上的暴力程度
on her was rough, unwarranted, and absolutely unjustified. While Judge Crossley observed that it was difficult to perceive any remorse in the fore, as they all accepted Joan's death was God's will, he did not use this as an aggravating factor due to the unusual nature of the case. He stated, You put Joan through an ordeal that can only be described as bizarre and quite extraordinary. Seen objectively, that ordeal was cruel. Yet, I do accept that you said about subjecting her to that ordeal, honestly believing that it was for her own good, and she was truly possessed by demons.
都是粗暴的、无端的，绝对是不合理的。尽管克罗斯利法官注意到很难从这四人身上看出任何悔意，因为他们都接受琼的死是上帝的旨意，但由于案件的特殊性质，他并未将此作为加重处罚的因素。他表示：“你让琼经历了一场只能被形容为离奇且非常非凡的磨难。从客观上看，那场磨难是残酷的。然而，我确实接受你们对她实施这种磨难的说法，你们是出于真诚地相信这是为了她好，而且她确实被恶魔附身了。”
Judge Crossley sentenced Leanne Reichenbach to two years in prison, 20 months of which were suspended for two years. David Klingner was given 18 months, 15 of which were also suspended for two years. Ralph Vollmer was sentenced to 12 months, suspended for two years, and Matthew Nusky received three months, suspended for 18 months. Of the four, only Leanne and David would serve any prison time. Leanne fought to hold back tears as she was escorted from the courtroom to begin her four-month sentence. Joan's family had deliberately avoided media attention since her death, but two members gave brief statements following the sentencing.
克罗斯利法官判处莉安·赖兴巴赫两年监禁，其中20个月缓刑两年。大卫·克林格被判处18个月监禁，其中15个月同样缓刑两年。拉尔夫·沃尔默被判处12个月监禁，缓刑两年，而马修·努斯基被判处3个月监禁，缓刑18个月。在这四人中，只有莉安和大卫需要服刑。莉安在被法庭护送出去开始她为期四个月的刑期时，强忍着泪水。琼的家族自她死后一直刻意避开媒体的关注，但有两名成员在宣判后发表了简短的声明。
One of her sisters, Dorothy, commented that Joan's death had traumatized their family, while another sister, Irene, added that she hoped the ordeal was finally over. Quote, it's just something we have to put behind us now. In May 1995, all four perpetrators appealed their convictions at the Supreme Court of Victoria. The defendants argued that the crown had failed to adequately show that by pressing on Joan's neck, they had caused her death, and claimed that the offensive manslaughter had not been committed, as Joan had consented to the acts that were performed on her. They also submitted that the charge of false imprisonment did not apply,
她的其中一个姐姐多萝西评论说，琼的死给他们的家庭带来了创伤，而另一个姐姐艾琳则补充说，她希望这场磨难终于结束了。“这只是我们现在必须抛在脑后的一件事。”1995年5月，四名罪犯在维多利亚州最高法院对他们的定罪提起上诉。被告辩称，皇家检察署未能充分证明他们通过按压琼的颈部导致了她的死亡，并声称由于琼同意了对她实施的行为，因此并未犯下严重的过失杀人罪。他们还辩称，非法拘禁罪并不适用，
as Joan's mental state and behavior meant she was a danger to herself and others, and she had agreed to, quote, necessary restraint. The perpetrators' attorneys also objected to some of the evidence applied by the prosecution, including exhibits of the wooden planks Joan's feet had been strapped to, portions of the police interviews with the defendants, and testimony regarding the destruction of the farm's garden and Joan's prized possessions. On September 7, 1995, the Supreme Court of Victoria rejected all grounds of appeal. And upheld the convictions.
因为琼的精神状态和行为意味着她对自己和他人构成了危险，并且她已经同意了“必要的约束”。罪犯们的律师还反对控方提供的一些证据，包括绑住琼双脚的木板实物、部分警方对被告的采访记录，以及关于农场花园和琼珍贵物品被毁坏的证词。1995年9月7日，维多利亚州最高法院驳回了所有的上诉理由，并维持了原判。
Little is known about the perpetrators' lives following their convictions, though all appear to have maintained their faith. Ralph Vollmer eventually married for a third time and left Victoria to live with his new wife in Queensland, selling his and Joan's Antwerp property in 2001. An editorial published in Melbourne newspaper The Age in September 1993 voiced the anxieties felt by much of the public in the wake of Joan's death, it read in part. Most Australians call themselves Christians, but most would have no doubt that the four who tried to exercise the mentally ill Joan Vollmer were dangerously deluded.
关于罪犯们被定罪后的生活人们知之甚少，尽管所有人似乎都保持了他们的信仰。拉尔夫·沃尔默最终结了第三次婚，并离开维多利亚州，与他的新妻子一起住在昆士兰州，并在2001年卖掉了他和琼在安特卫普的房产。墨尔本报纸《时代报》于1993年9月发表的一篇社论表达了琼死后公众大部分感到的焦虑，其中部分内容写道：大多数澳大利亚人都自称是基督徒，但大多数人无疑会认为，试图为精神生病的琼·沃尔默驱魔的那四个人是受到危险妄想的蒙蔽。
How can such medieval thinking persist in the face of modern medicine's ability to diagnose mental disturbance? The Vollmer case demonstrates the darker side of some forms of belief and the dangers of religious certainty. Those who do not question their actions, who carry within them the assurance of divine inspiration at all times, are capable of harm that is as great as it is unknowing. For the past 20 years, the farmhouse where Joan was killed has lain empty. The buyers who purchased it in 2001 never moved in. It sold again in 2013 for just under $87,500 but remained uninhabited. According to an article published in 2016 by news.com.au, breaking into the abandoned residence has become a popular pastime for local teenagers.
面对现代医学诊断心理障碍的能力，这种中世纪思维怎么能持续存在？沃尔默案展示了某些形式信仰的黑暗面以及宗教确定性的危险。那些不对自己的行为提出质疑、始终怀揣着神圣灵感确信的人，能够造成与他们的无知同样巨大的伤害。在过去的20年里，琼被杀害的农舍一直空无一人。2001年买下它的买家从未搬进去。它在2013年以略低于87,500美元的价格再次售出，但仍然无人居住。根据news.com.au于2016年发表的一篇文章，闯入这座废弃的住宅已成为当地青少年的热门消遣方式。
Ivan Pollack, the Antwerp resident who spoke of the communities discussed in the wake of Joan's death, told reporter Candice Sutton that the house made people feel unsettled. Quote, It put Antwerp on the map, so to speak. People still talk about what happened in that house. Nearly 60 kilometers south, a simple headstone marks Joan Vollmer's final resting place at Horsham Cemetery. Beneath the rendering of a crucifix and her name are the words, always in our hearts, in God's care. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
伊万·波拉克是那位在琼死后谈论社区讨论的安特卫普居民，他告诉记者坎迪斯·萨顿，这栋房子让人感到不安。“可以说，它让安特卫普名声大噪。人们仍在谈论那栋房子里发生的事情。”大约在向南60公里处，一块简单的墓碑标志着琼·沃尔默在霍舍姆公墓的最终安息之地。在十字架的图案和她的名字下方是这样的话：“永远在我们心中，在上帝的照顾下。”目前这一集还没有评论。点击字幕中的任何句子即可发表评论。